britney spears's instagram account was
deactivated but the pop star says it's
no cause for alarm
i just want to be a happy person here's
what went down
fans noticed britney's ig account
disappeared from the platform on tuesday
immediately inciting concern amongst her
followers amid the singer's ongoing
conservatorship battle but within a few
hours brittany took to twitter to
explain quote don't worry folks just
taking a little break from social media
to celebrate my engagement i'll be back
soon
i'm very keen on freedom i love freedom
i love independence a source is also
shedding light on the situation telling
e.t quote nothing should be read into
this she previously said she'd be taking
a well-deserved break as many
celebrities do that's really it
as for any conspiracy theories
surrounding the account deactivation
well the source says those are wrong and
you guys know my situation the social
media snafu comes on the heels of an
eventful week in the pop star's personal
life
this is just a groundbreaking day last
week her father jamie spears filed a
petition to end her 13-year long
conservatorship in court documents
obtained by e.t jamie states that
britney is quote entitled to have this
court now seriously consider whether
this conservatorship is no longer
required
in a statement to e.t brittany's
attorney matthew rosengart said the
filing represents a massive legal
victory and vindication for the pop star
less than two weeks ago we pledged
that after 13 years of the status quo
my firm and i would move aggressively
and expeditiously
to file a petition to suspend
and remove james p spears
another huge life update britney's
longtime boyfriend sam askari is putting
a ring on it
look at that
you like it yeah
britney shared this video on sunday
writing in the caption i can't [ __ ]
believe it
among the many well wishes in the
comments were also calls for britney to
be careful with her estate
one that had everyone talking came from
oscar winner octavia spencer who got
right to the point writing quote make
him sign a prenup
well as for sam he saw the comments and
had a little fun when addressing the
concerns in his instagram story
thank you everyone who is concerned
about the prenup of course we're getting
an iron-clad prenup to protect my jeep
and shoe collection in case she dumps me
one day
[Music]
brittany and sam began dating after they
met on the set of her music video for
slumber party and in 2019 he opened up
about their special bond
i love the most about my relationship is
the fact that it's it's so normal you
know it's not anything glad like you
said it's not glamorous or anything she
inspires me in my work and also i can
give so much to her by going to the gym
by by going to work by having an actual
balanced life you know we can get
inspired by each other here and there
and really grow with each other